[Musik]
waschmittel prozessen ist bisher das
team des jahres und zum glück das ja
gerade erst angefangen
es geht um solche waschmittel ports ihr
in den usa am beliebtesten von der firma
teilt viele machen sich einen spaß aus
der idee teil potts zu essen tatsächlich
ist das ein problem bei kleinen kindern
welche die waschmittel ports mit
süßigkeiten verwechseln leider gibt es
immer mehr mutige sag ich jetzt mal
jugendliche welche die type challenge
ernsthaft durchziehen und sich dabei
filmen wie sie sich selbst vergiften
euch doch einfach alle um der
amerikanische verbraucherschutz hat sich
inzwischen eingeschaltet die vier mal
teilt selbst halt dieses video mit
franck also nicht unserem grunde leben
american football player rob gronkowski
hochgeladen und youtube hat angefangen
teilt challenge videos zu löschen um den
gefährlichen trend nicht weiter
ausbreiten zu lassen da frage ich mich
doch ist dieser trend wirklich so
gefährlich kann man dieses ding
vielleicht nicht doch essen wenn man die
wissenschaft dahinter kennt aber die
type challenge hat mich zu einem
vielleicht neuen format inspiriert denn
nur weil ein internet trennt dumme ist
heißt das nicht dass man ihn nicht
wissenschaftlich erklären kann und dabei
sehr interessante sachen lernen kann
deswegen herzlich willkommen zur ersten
folge von nay erklärt
wie genau funktioniert so ein
waschmittel pott und was passiert wenn
man ihn jetzt also der selling point
dieser waschmittel potts ist die leichte
handhabung man wird so ein pott einfach
in die waschmaschine ist es alles genau
vor dosiert und es gibt kein klecker so
weit so praktisch wir haben es hier laut
hersteller mit 3 in 1 spots zu tun
dank dieser kammer technologie kann man
nun endlich drei verschiedene
eigenschaften kombiniert nämlich erstens
tiefen sauber zweitens fleck lösen
das natürlich in den aktiven sauberkeit
ist ja schon mal wünschenswert aber wenn
es dann auch noch blicken löst und
drittens strahlend rein tiefen sauber
und strahlend rein sind natürlich zwei
völlig unterschiedliche eigenschaften
und ich wusste gar nicht dass man diese
in einem pott kombinieren kann wie wir
damit sagen ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass man diese drei sachen auch einfach
von vornherein wissen kann wie bei einem
normalen waschmittel aber dann sehe das
natürlich nicht sofern sie aus die
inhaltsstoffe sind hier nur sehr vage
aufgelistet ist wohl firmengeheimnis
deswegen kann ich nicht genau sagen was
in diesen verschiedenen kann man drin
ist aber es würde mich nicht wundern
wenn der hauptunterschied einfach nur
der farbstoff ist was natürlich nicht
heißt dass hier nicht ganz viel
faszinierende chemie drin steckt und die
gehen wir jetzt mal durch sagen wir doch
mal mit dieser faszinierenden hülle an
aus was besteht die es ist jedenfalls
irgendein polymer das nicht auf der
inhalts liste des herstellers steht aber
ich gehe davon aus dass es sich hier
höchstwahrscheinlich um pulli vinyl
alkohol handelt polyalkohole kann man
diese wasserlöslichen filme bilden die
sich in der waschmaschine dann auflösen
und das waschmittel freisetzen bei
sämtlichen filmen kunststoffen usw
handelt es sich übrigens immer und
polymere polymere sind lange
molekülketten unsere hülle hier
polyalkohole besteht aus ketten
segmenten die so aussehen und an der oha
gruppe erkennt man übrigens auch dass
sich dieses pole mehr so gut mit wasser
h2o versteht und sich deswegen auch
darin auflöst diese hülle ist übrigens
dünn bzw löst sich so gut in wasser das
sich diesen pott diese spot noch nicht
mal für ein sammel in den mund nehmen
würde weil es sich so schnell in wasser
aufgelöst kommen wir zum inhalt
inhaltsstoffe sind wie gesagt nicht im
detail aufgelistet aber ich werde sie
trotzdem mal durchgeht der größte und
wichtigste bestandteil von waschmitteln
sind tenside es gibt verschiedenste
arten von tensiden aber vom prinzip her
sind tenside so aufgebaut wie eine
stecknadel sie haben einen kopf der es
hydrophil also wasser liegt und einen
hydro vom schwanz normalerweise
verstehen sich die profile und
hydrophobe sachen nicht so gut deswegen
mischen sich ja auch wasser und öl nicht
weil tensiden versteht sich jetzt aber
dein kopf super mit wasser und der
schwanz versteht sich super mit ölen
fetten und organischen stoffen diese
eigenschaft nennt man am fiel sowohl
hydrophil als auch wie tofu was ist
jetzt so besonders an solchen am vielen
eigenschaften weil hydro vieles gerne
mit hydrophilem abhängt und hydro vobis
gerne mit mikroben formieren sich diese
tenside zu größeren gruppen wenn sie in
lösung sind könnte es gerne bei
wikipedia nachschauen da ist es
eigentlich ganz gut visualisiert wenn
die tenside einfach so ins wasser
schmeißt bilden sich mit zellen die
müsst ihr euch dreidimensional
vorstellen also zum beispiel kugeln
außen sitzen die hydrophilen köpfe und
schauen zum wasser und innen sind die
hydrophoben schwänze quasi vom wasser
versteckt am viele stoffe sind aber auch
grenzflächen aktiv so sagt man dem sie
informieren sich sehr gerne an
grenzflächen so eine grenzfläche kann
zum beispiel die grenze zwischen wasser
und öl sollen hier sieht man wie die
tenside ähnlich wie bei der hmi zähne
einen öltropfen in wasser stabilisieren
können nimmt auch die grenzfläche
zwischen wasser luft können tenside
stabilisieren ihr wisst ohne seife also
ohne tenside keiner seifenblasen und
auch kein durchschauen und letztendlich
mögen die tenside auch die grenzflächen
zwischen fest und flüssig das heißt zum
beispiel zwischen wasser und schmutz auf
der kleidung die tenside formieren sich
um die schmutzpartikel und lösen sie so
von der klein und dann haben wir hier
noch enzyme viele flecken lassen sich
durch tenside entfernen aber wenn jetzt
ein fleck besonders eiweiß
protein reich ist zum beispiel ein eier
flac oder blut an braucht man denn züge
enzyme sind selbst große proteine oder
eiweißmoleküle die dazu in der lage sind
andere eiweiße zu zersetzen und
abzubauen
neben tänzen und enzymen sind in voll
waschmitteln auch bleichmittel enthalten
gleich mittel sind moleküle die beim
waschen zuerst wasserstoffperoxid und
dann sauerstoff freisetzen der
sauerstoff reagiert dann mit verfärbten
schmutz und so weiter durch oxidation
und verwandelt den schmutz in farblose
verbindung und natürlich greift das auch
die normalen textilfarben an was auch
genau der grund ist warum klamotten nach
häufigem waschen verblassen deswegen
sind feinwaschmittel auch kein
bleichmittel drin in dieser inhalte
steht jetzt auch nichts konkretes aber
ich gehe davon aus dass ihr gleich
mittendrin sind weil hier auch phosphor
narrte drin sind haus formate sind
sogenannte komplexbildner die
metallionen zum beispiel spuren von
schwermetallen einfangen einpacken und
abschirmen können was hat das ganze mit
bleichmitteln zu tun gleich mittel sind
meter stabile moleküle denn sie sollen
ja beim waschen zerfallen in
wasserstoffperoxid und dann den
sauerstoff diese reaktion wird
katalysiert das heißt beschleunigt durch
kleinste mengen an metallionen und wenn
man diese nicht abschieben es mit diesen
komplexbildner dann zerfallen die
bleichmittel noch bevor man sie benutzt
in der waschmaschine und davos formate
typische komplexbildner sind also
stabilisatoren für bleichmittel gehe ich
mal stark davon aus dass hier auch
gleich mittendrin sind dann sind hier
noch optische aufheller drin das sind
keine bleichmittel sondern moleküle die
uv licht absorbieren und im gegenzug
bläulich aussehen die blaue farbe soll
den gelbstich kompensieren den vor allem
weiße klamotten mit der zeit bekommen
ist also eine rein optische maßnahmen
und hat eigentlich gar nichts mit der
reinheit zu tun
ansonsten sind sie noch verschiedene
duftstoffe drin die mit sicherheit gut
riechen und mit genau so großer
sicherheit nicht schmecke ich werde
nicht für euch testen wie ein
waschmittel pott schmeckt aber ich denke
jeder der mal unter der dusche aus
versehen auch nur ein bisschen shampoo
in den mund bekommen
weiß dass es nicht so gut schmeckt so
interessant die chemie hinter dem
waschmittel ist so zeigt sie doch
gleichzeitig warum man diese dinger
nicht unbedingt in seinem mund seiner
speiseröhre oder sein verdauungssystem
haben möchte
auch wenn man so einen potash ba ist
dann scheint es natürlich erst mal ohne
ende stichwort tenside grenzflächen
aktivität stabilisierung von bläschen
dann wären sicherlich ganz viele fette
lipide proteine in unserem körper
abgelöst oder zersetzt alle gleich
mittel und auch einige tänze sind reits
sind und in hohen konzentrationen
erzeugt vor allem für schleimhäute
generell sind die proxy die von dem
bleichmittel freigesetzt werden sehr
reaktive und aggressive substanzen die
nicht nur fahrt moleküle oxidieren
können sondern natürlich alles möglich
in unserem körper und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das basische waschmittel
in unserem sauren verdauungssystem im
zuge einer neutralisation reaktion
besonders stark schäumt bauchschmerzen
durchfall und erbrechen sind die
häufigsten folgen mit denen ein gesunder
erwachsener noch davonkommen kann aber
vor allem im zuge des verbrechens und
des starken schäumen schaumkuss stellt
euch das mal vor kann natürlich auch
schaum in die atemwege gelangen was
tödlich sein kann vor allem für kinder
und eltern
damit habe ich hoffentlich meine pflicht
zur aufklärung erfüllt und wir können
nur hoffen dass sich dieser trend nicht
auch weiter verbreitet aber wenn es
youtube trends gibt die ihr gerne von
mir wissen schaftliche erklärt haben
möchtet dann schreibt sie in die
kommentare
wir sehen uns nächste woche bis dahin
bleibt sicher und es kein waschmittel
bitte
bringt euch doch einfach alle um